hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about four ways to decalcify your
arteries now if you've been watching my
videos you already know about health
Aikido and you also know about in a
minute fasting okay because that's the
initial thing that you need to do to
help reduce insulin and help the
oxidation on your arteries because
calcium and cholesterol come in later as
a band-aid to help heal the lesions or
the damaged artery wall so if you can
imagine if you have a hole in the wall
you would use a spackle to patch it up
right same thing with the body uses
calcium cholesterol and a couple of
other things so if you're doing keto
intermittent fasting you're gonna
actually lessen that damage in the
artery wall okay
and also I recommend getting this test
right here called the coronary artery
calcium score or test CAC you can ask
your doctor to do it because it allows
you to see the calcium in the arteries
and it's on a different rating scoring
system you want it as close to zero as
possible and it's very important to get
a baseline so as you do your program
your healthy eating program or lifestyle
program you can see changes for the
better okay that's a very very important
now there are four different types of
nutrients that are recommended to pull
calcium out of the arteries number one
vitamin k2 what is vitamin k2 it's a fat
soluble vitamin that has a function of
transporting excess calcium from places
where it shouldn't be
to places where it should be into the
bone so it removes it from the joint and
the arteries and pushes it into the bone
there's a couple different versions I'm
gonna recommend the natural version
which is mk7 okay alright number two
about them in d3 vitamin d3 works with
k2 they're both fat soluble vitamins and
I do recommend them with a meal not an
empty stomach because they'll be
absorbed better but vitamin D is
intimately involved in the
transportation of calcium so these work
together all right number three
magnesium magnesium is very important if
you have excess calcium because if you
increase magnesium it'll help lower the
calcium in the body it's kind of like a
teeter-totter effect then we have the
last one called ip6
or phytic acid and
so tall HECO phosphate you don't need to
know that all you need to know is ip6 is
a great inhibitor of calcification in
your arteries okay it's a key later so
it binds with calcium and other minerals
like iron especially and it helps to
pull it out of the arteries okay
very powerful so these are the four
remedies I would recommend in addition
to healthy ketosis and in a minute
fasting thanks for watching hey I
appreciate your attention and if you're
enjoying these videos go ahead and
subscribe and I will definitely keep you
updated on future events live events and
webinars that we're going to do very
soon